[Music]
the entire farm storyline was wrapped up
in one final episode and let's just say
it went out with a fizzle and not with a
bang get it cuz of the rocket okay
hey liver babes I'm your host Leon
Aguilera and this is your Sweetwater
Secrets after-show for episode 403
chapter 60 Dog Day Afternoon today we'll
be highlighting your hisses and kisses
from this ultra crazy episode plus I'm
gifting you with a very long interview
with the lovely Lilly Reinhardt shouting
all about this episode's farm freight
frenzy what's coming up next for the
Jones Cooper house and what kind of
romantic scenes are ahead for Buckhead
but first let's try to recap the biggest
moments of the night with the blue and
gold breakdown goodness gracious
where do I begin now bear with me guys
I'm a little confused because usually we
have to wait until like episodes 16 for
such a chaotic hour so I'm a little bit
cobbled let's go an order of craziness
so we'll start with the least insane
storyline of the week and that is
Jughead started a new school again now
apparently Stonewall Prep is a weekday
boarding school so Jughead is rooming
with ultra preppy Brett and moose well
actually he goes by Marmaduke now and if
yours confused with me then yeah because
he's supposed to be in Glendale with his
aunt but whatever anyways by the end of
the episode Jughead and Brett tried to
out pretentious each other tried to
fight each other decide that they hate
each other and then Bret proved to be
the absolute worst and outed Marmaduke's
gargoyle King past douche move I'm just
gonna say it
not cool Bret now next up on the not to
crazy side of things Archie wanted to
turn the El Royale boxing gym into a
community center so basically all we
need to do is take away from our Chi
storyline this week is that the writers
gave us a shirtless carwash themed to
make up for the fact that Riverdale is
officially nothing like it was in season
one there's apparently yet another drug
dealing gang causing trouble and they
talk about the small town like it's
radioactive
so Archie's answer to this is to dress
up like a vigilante
fight them and to try and give their
dirty money to his girlfriend Veronica
sidenote where the hell are the serpents
are they just totally gone inque cool
anyway so
Archie's mom decides to stay in
Riverdale which is really confusing
because his father just passed away so
you think she'd hope she'd stay in town
but she's gonna say and help him run and
manage the center so yeah also Veronica
is no longer Veronica Lodge nor Veronica
Gomez she's officially going by Veronica
Luna after her paternal grandfather do I
like it sure well I call her that note
as for Sheryl and Tony at wealth Nanna
Rose dropped off freakin blossom
bombshell on us and may have just
revealed that Sheryl has a long-lost
sibling because apparently Penelope
blossom had triplets oh and Tony hired a
weird hunky male nurse to help look
after things and one thing led to
another and yeah
Tony totally discovered that Cheryl's
been keeping her dead brother's corpse
in the Thistle House basement awkward
and last but certainly not least because
this storyline was beyond wild Betty
broke into the farm now it started off
with Charles aka the worst cop ever
trying to talk Betty through defusing a
bomb that was attached to Polly yes I'm
serious I don't know why Charles didn't
just do it himself but okay and Betty
used one of her trusty bobby pins to
defuse the bomb and yeah Betty what the
heck anyways now that wasn't enough for
you oh just get ready because Betty
stole a school bus and tried to rescue
her mom from Edgar and Evelyn's clutches
and Betty and Alice were tied up and
then they escaped and betting at the
farm ease onto a bus and then Alice
found edgar trying to escape on a rocket
that's right a rocket and goodness
gracious
Alice proved herself to be the baddest
we've always known she isn't she shot
and killed Edgar now in all future
parties
if someone says never have I ever killed
a cult leader named Edgar ever never
Allison's definitely going to have to
drink I'm exhausted so please enjoy this
interview of lily Reinhardt talking all
about all things Betty and bug head for
season four while I take a minute
well let's fill in the puzzle a little
bit for Miss Betty Cooper what is life
like for her now that her father is dead
I don't think you're coming back from
that one and her mother is a secret FBI
informant who's actually living in a
cult and trying to confuse all of them
and to believe in that she's actually a
real number Alice must be a method actor
if she really had me fooled
you know you think back to like the
baptism I'm like Alice really went for
it hmm and I think Betty is happily
settling into her her home here in
Cooper Jones house I feel like it took a
minute but she's happy and I think it
brings her closer to Jughead even though
he's at the prep school which is hard
because they're doing the long-distance
sort of thing but Betty was really
supportive in him chasing after his
writing dreams and going to that school
to get himself the best education so
they're you know there's a lot of
long-distance phone calls and sort of
checking in with each other like that
so is Jughead living at the prep school
is it like a boarding school okay cuz I
was gonna say I'm like well hey they're
under the same roof but not quite only
on the weekends okay you better take
your brakes for me while you can Cooper
just you and I are in this for long haul
okay could we expect to see any happy
moments between Betty and Jughead yeah I
think so I mean I can imagine there are
yeah I mean there definitely are they
don't spend too much time together while
he's in morning school he's got his own
problems happening over there and
Betty's kind of taking care of things on
the home front but they definitely when
they meet in the middle it's it's a
little happy happy reunion are we gonna
see Betty get closer to FP and jelly
beans and she's living with them I think
so you definitely see in the Halloween
episode at least Betty and jellybeans
spend some time together and jelly beans
a tough nut to crack in order to like
relate to her so
Betty's trying she's kind of like the
babysitter at one point and
I think it's weird for her to be around
FP and this sort of like almost father
figure sense but I don't know it could
be very sweet in a way I think I would
love to see FB become a father figure to
Betty that would actually be really
endearing yeah yeah well especially cuz
fans still love FP analysis so much so
much any happy endings for them like I
think so yeah yeah I think they're
headed they're glad the farmer opens you
up to the possibility of us I don't know
if there's any more cold so I think that
may be laid to rest mm-hmm yes mmm
Edgar ascended and were you happy that
that was laid to rest I was like wow
that was a lot of buildup for very quick
resolve but it was fun it was a fun
little victorious moment for Betty and
for Alice and I wait for them to kind of
work together which was which is really
fun yeah quite quite victorious for them
I mean clearly Cheryl is still left with
some brainwashing and and I think Alice
has a lot of you know adjusting to her
life as she needs to do there's a lot of
changes going on but I think Cheryl's
going back to an open environment with
Tony hopefully and analysis going back
to her daughter
thank God hopefully they can repair what
has been lost definitely I love
everything that Lily told me in that
interview but especially about Betty and
Jughead making it work while he's away
which leads me into our most romantic
moments of the night was seven seconds
in heaven hmm
okay well spoiler alert we didn't have
much this week but here's a little peek
at the moments that made us swoon
because oh my goodness gracious
okay this bug-head scene was just so
sensational I love that he said that
they're in for the long haul you know we
got those cuddles on the couch before
they were rudely interrupted and then
Shoney's sneaking us in some bedtime
cuddles okay but the real star of the
night is
aka Marmaduke and some girl named Donna
what's up Donna I don't know if I trust
you but welcome to Riverdale and that
was it
that was all we got we did get like an
alluding moment with Archie that was
nice but it was a pretty crazy episode
so yeah I know I'm dying to hear
everything that you all had to say about
chapter 60 Dog Day Afternoon so let's go
over all the highs and lows witnesses
and kisses now as always I called out on
Twitter and we have our first tweet from
Ryan Sprouse 97 and they wrote kisses to
Edgar's rocket scene peak Riverdale
kisses hmm I was gonna go with hisses
but it seems like you guys are a little
bit mixed let's talk about Edgar in this
episode I thought that Chad Michael
Murray was absolutely sensational as
unhinged Edgar I loved this whole vibe I
liked the shirtless scenes because I'm
yeah and I thought he did such a great
job but this let's talk about this
outfit
goodness gracious it's Edgar evil
knievel and as you can tell I'm kind of
channeling him today but I don't know
how I feel about evil Edgar you guys
tell me let's go through some of your
comments right now because you all have
a lot of thoughts about Edgar in this
episode okay we have mm-hmm
Goldie Fitzpatrick saying kisses to
Alice were shooting Edgar very fair
Paulina says kisses to Edgar for being
so freakin hot hehe yeah let's that's
very true that's a very true statement
he is very hot um let's see what else we
have Aaron Brown says was I the only one
confused about the farm the rocket and
evil Edgar Knievel you know Roberto had
warned us saying that episode 403 was
going to be the most insane episode ever
and I feel like you know we spent so
much time dealing with the farm in
season two that they were just like you
might as well go out with a bang I would
have loved to see him on the rocket
though
our next tweet comes from BJ our one 277
and they said hisses to Edgar for a dumb
escape plan a rocket yeah this is to
Cheryl for turning into Riverdale's
Norman Bates and hisses to Archie for
being so stubborn I agree with that
let's talk about Archie in this episode
because I actually have a hiss about
this obviously he is going through a lot
right now and we see that but the fact
that he decided to suit up as they say
an arrow grabbed his bat and a mask and
decided to fight the crime himself well
you know what I just don't know how I
because I feel like we've already seen
this storyline with the whole red circle
or that whole situation but I'm gonna
give Archie a pass for like nine more
episodes and then we'll circle back with
that let's see what you guys have to say
um Monique wick says his assistant Anna
Rose looking at Cheryl and referring to
her as Penelope Nana Rose can do
whatever she wants truly and I'm glad
that she thought she was Penelope
because we are getting some secrets that
we didn't know anything about like let's
talk about the fact that Cheryl might
have a long-lost sibling and somebody
was asking me about it they said Oh Ruth
is not high okay says LeAnn who do you
think could be the third blossom kid I
think they're gonna introduce someone
new or what they could do is how the
actors who played Jason blossom play it
would be like two twins like two twin
boys and then Cheryl and then that way
we could actually hear the after you
plays Jason blossom talks because it's
been four years and we've never actually
heard him say a word did anyone else
notice that it's kind of insane by at
this point um okay we have Goldie okay
we have Katina Val Cova said Tony said
she found that Darius guy online are we
sure she wasn't on tinder where she
found it because I mean that guy was hot
I mean I guess he was attractive if you
look really tall muscular guys who were
wearing scrubs but I did think that
whole situation was very creepy why was
he in the basement did he move Jason's
dead Bluff a dead body
blossom body and the rats coming out of
his stomach and that Cheryl's just
sewing up ourselves let's talk about
fact that Tony finally found out the
truth how do you think they're gonna
react
how she gonna react to this well I will
tell you a very special secret so next
Wednesday that is the day of the
Halloween Riverdale episode I am giving
all you Shoney's fans out there an
exclusive interview with Vanessa Morgan
and Madeline patch together I know you
showed me fans are so excited and we
talked about everything from Shoney's
dream date to the fact that Tony now
knows about Jason to their unconditional
love yes that is a direct quote from one
of them you guys are going to love it so
stay tuned so many fun things coming up
for you guys
Lily Eve Davies says LeAnn do you think
they will kill off jug my answer is no I
do not think they will kill off jug if
they do then something has gone terribly
wrong ah Kiera Emison says his just a
hiram for escaping prison and scaring
his daughter yes I completely agree and
our next tweet actually comes from Julia
Shepherd - 91 who says kisses - Veronica
4 yet again standing up to Hiram and
changing her name and kisses to Jughead
for standing up to that bully Brett or
whatever his name is and hisses - Hiram
for being a hiram and hisses - Edgar for
putting Polly in grave danger
oh my gosh that Polly scene I can't even
but going back to Veronica I really want
to talk about her in this episode
because she is just so incredibly
generous and so incredibly rich I cannot
get over the fact that she was just
first of all it was so sweet for her to
arrange this car wash and try and help
the boys out but the fact that she was
willing to give $40,000 to Archie's mom
as just like a there you go
can you imagine just giving away like
400 or 4,000 let alone being like oh
yeah I got a spare $40,000 they want you
to have it that is love and a lot I
don't know how I feel about that
right it's just a lot it's just a lot
let's see we have a sweet Oh comment
from Cassidy 12 and says will there be
more core for I miss them feel like we
find a lot of core for so far this
season but of course will it's we're
going back to season 1 but you're gonna
be getting a lot more core 4 so I think
that's gonna be really nice
um cutie-pie four four two seven one
zero zero lot of numbers in the next
preview I'm so confused as to who is the
black hood now that hal is dead
the halloween episode guys anything can
happen and I'm really excited because
that was the episode that I was on set
for so in next week's Sweetwater
after-show I will be giving you all a
very long package with all your favorite
stars feeling behind the scenes secrets
about the episode what the actors
themselves like to do for Halloween
it was super fun we had such a fun time
you guys are going to love it oh and
also next week
yeah we're just go so much sweet letter
next week I have a really fun package
for you guys coming on Monday and it's
called trick-or-treat and I asked all
your favorites a trick question and a
treat question and their answers are so
cute I think you're gonna explode in the
best possible way okay we have a couple
more comments let's see
Sonia Quintero says by the way
Sweetwater Secrets gets me through the
week
ah Sonya thank you so much it gets me
through my week as well a lot of work
goes into producing these episodes for
you guys especially when they're live
like this so big shout out to my crew of
my editors and everyone right now who
are doing such a great job behind the
scenes you can't see them but I know who
they are and also to my girl l4 this
makeup yes guys I have makeup on today's
exciting okay let's see we just have a
couple more that I'm going to read off
from you guys cuz you guys are giving so
much okay LPS lime W says kisses to
Shoni for helping each other and for
Toni caring about Nana Rose everyone
should care about Nana rose and didi
says big kiss to Alice at Betty's slow
walk scene like damn that was flippin
cool exactly and that leads me to our
last tweet which is from F nation's girl
and she wrote kisses to Alice for taking
down a whole ass cult like the badass
she is I'm so happy to have Alice back
and have machen on my screen morgen
finally oh you're speaking my language
first of all matron emic is amazing and
also the badass Cooper ladies let's take
a look at these seeds because goodness
gracious knocking out Evelyn was the
most satisfying thing this slow motion
seen as a
her punching things so many good moments
and I don't know about you but I'm
digging this new haircut on Alice she
looks so fierce with a gun I don't
condone violence but I'm sorry
Edgar you deserved it but truly I could
have an entire episode that's just the
Cooper women going off and being awesome
but what I'm excited about is that as
Lily said in our interview we are
getting a real blended family it's now
the Cooper Jones house so you know Alice
is gonna be moving in with F P when I
talk to the parents I said we're finally
gonna get a kissing scene which is very
exciting but I'm really excited to see
how this whole family kind of blends
together it's weird when you think
really hard about it about the fact that
the parents are together and the kids
are together but we're not going to
focus too much on that right now we're
just gonna focus on the fact that we're
getting more Betty and jellybean scenes
which I'm really excited about we're
gonna read just a couple more comments
from you guys so I'm just came in right
now Michaela Taylor yeah
sis Sheryl as poison ivy and Tony as
Harley Quinn I'm ready for next week oh
it's gonna be good you're gonna have to
full look at their outfits have them
talking about it
oh you guys are gonna I don't know
what's gonna happen Andrew Valdez said
it could be snowing in Riverdale and
Archie would still be shirtless this is
very true
and you know what KJ sign with that he
puts in the work show it off KJ be proud
do your thing um
roo-roo says anyone else think Edgar ate
dead I'm gonna I'm really sad to see
Chad Michael Murray go I thought he was
fantastic in this last episode but man I
don't know I also don't know about
Charles what do you guys think because I
don't trust him and I think that as we
go further down the line we're gonna
start to see that we're gonna see him
interact more with FP and Alice and kind
of understand that but the fact that
he's just telling Betty the entire time
like this is how you defuse a bomb okay
you do it you do it Charles if you know
what you're doing why are you sending
your little sister up to go defuse your
other sisters bomb I don't know yeah
Betty though
got we should all just start having
bobby pins in our hair anywhere it
doesn't even have to be doing anything
just pull one out randomly there yeah
yeah I ran out of things to say thank
you so much for watching this after show
for 403 and get ready for a spook tastic
week of Sweetwater next week because
I'll be bringing you three amazing new
episodes of Sweetwater including a fun
trick-or-treat game with a cast an
exclusive show knee interview with
Madeline and Vanessa and behind the
scenes interviews from the Halloween
episode you don't want to miss it
now until then you guys know what to do
hit subscribe give this video a like and
then hit the comments or tweet me with
your thoughts now what are you most
hoping to see in the Halloween episode
are you happy that the farm is finally
done and what do you think about the new
Cooper Jones house hmm
tell me everything and I'll see you soon
river babes kisses to you
[Music]